top je suis l'une des industries
françaises les plus florissantes ces
dernières années le tourisme
je participe au rayonnement du savoir
faire français autour du globe et permet
à l'industrie française de créer chaque
année plus en plus le luxe
non c'est non il est d'usagé de dire il
ya peu que le commerce des bananes
autour du monde était plus d'un quart
avec le mien je suis je suis je suis
l'un d'eux gérard mémoire c'est oui ces
oublis - on dirait que commerce de la
banane
seriously alors déjà petite info
intéressante le marché de la défense
dans le monde c'est plus de 100 fois le
budget du maintien de la paix les états
unis a tout misé clairement le marché et
reste le plus gros exportateur mondial
avec plus de 30 % de part de marché
entre 2011 et 2015
en france on tourne en général à 5% et
autour de la 5e place année après année
avec d'autres pays comme la chine
l'allemagne ou le royaume uni
et pourquoi je peux pas être plus précis
sur notre classement et bien parce que
les montants des contrats sont tellement
colossaux qu'une simple signature peut
modifier l'ordre des pays sur le podium
alors c'est vrai depuis des dizaines
d'années en france on sait faire des
armes vous avez tous depuis votre
naissance entendu parler des rafales
admirer notre super porte-avions qu'on
l'ait pas en réparation et baver devant
nos démonstrations de force chaque année
au 14 juillet même si on vrai le seul
truc intéressant le 14 juillet c'est le
défilé de la légion étrangère qui
respire la bad a three avec toute une
armée qui se battaient à la hache avant
que ce soit cool bref on a un savoir
faire plutôt élevée en la matière pour
un pays de taille mais la vraie
nouveauté depuis 2014
c'est qu'on commence à savoir les vendre
ou pas ce que fait pendant des années on
a qu'elle raie à écouler notre
production d'armes aux autres pays mais
depuis peu et peut-être grâce à jean
yves le drian ministre de la défense
super vrp et sulfateuse en chef de la
signature de contrat on cartonne un peu
partout dans le monde après un coup nous
en 2012 avec 4 8 milliards d'euros les
chiffres n'ont cessé progresser 6,8
milliards en 2013 8 2 milliards en 2014
on se met même la seconde place du
classement avec 16 9 milliards en 2015
et pour 2016 avec la vente récente de 36
rafale à l'inde un premier contrat signé
en vue de la production de 12 sous
marins pour l'australie on pourrait même
explosé le record historique de 16 9
milliards d'euros de ventes militaires
atteints l'an dernier mais vendre des
armes c'est avant des 40 ça en moins
aimables en plus on a une vraie
rentabilité de ce que l'on produit et à
qui on le voit et on pourrait se dire
qu'il s'agit d'un marché immoral indigne
d'un pays qui interdit le port d'armes
et qui se veut défenseur des libertés et
des droits de l'homme alors pourquoi on
continue
déjà parce que
c'est essentiel au développement notre
propre stratégie de défense un quoi
qu'on en pense
la france n'est plus aujourd'hui la
superpuissance qu'elle a pu être maîtres
de plus en plus difficile de rivaliser
avec des pays de la taille des us de la
russie ou la chine
au global ou en terme de budget de
développement de défense du coup pour
pouvoir rester à la pointe
on vend pour supporter une partie du
poids des dépenses de la défense
à titre d'exemple sans l'exportation
dans les dernières années de minimum 40
rafale fabriqués par dassault et retenez
bien ce nom parce qu'il est important
toute la programmation militaire
envisagée pour les années à venir aurait
pu s'écrouler
faute de moyens budgétaires suffisants
pour soutenir seul plus longtemps la
production en france
on continue aussi parce que comme on
vend on crée des emplois l'industrie de
la défense en france pèse aujourd'hui
165 mille emplois directs et indirects
et devrait dépasser les 200 mille
emplois vers 2018 grâce aux contrats
récents qui ont peut être signé et enfin
on continue parce qu'en restant à la
pointe de la technologie cela contribue
à son rayonnement et à l'image de
puissance qu'elle envoie ce qui permet
de vendre plus d'armes et donc de faire
travailler plus de gens et donc de
rester à la pointe un super cercle
vertueux
sauf que c'est pas si vertueuse que ça
déjà lorsque les médias parlent de
contrat il oublie de mentionner
certaines contreparties
prenons le cas par exemple des super
contrat des douze sous marins
australiens
nombreux sont les médias qui ont
mentionné que la somme s'élevait à 34
milliards sauf que c'est faux puisque
une partie sera reversée aux autres pays
qui vont travailler sur ces sous marins
ce qui laissera à la france une somme de
8 milliards d'euros
et attention 1,8 milliard c'est moins
que 34 mais c'est déjà ça et dans le
contexte de crise actuelle c'est super
et on devrait pouvoir créer plein dans
pau avec tout cet argent
sauf que non c'est sans compter sur les
contreparties qu'ils sont un peu
particulières un car si en france on
fabrique des armes on développe des
technologies à vendre entre autres
poursuit et l'emploi en australie on
achète des armes
bon ces mules et l'emploi comment eh
bien lorsque la france signe un contrat
pareil elle s'engage à réinvestir un
pourcentage de l'argent touché dans le
pays de son partenaire commercial à
titre de compensation c'est ce qu'on
appelle les of 7
dans le cas de l'australie on parle de
faire construire des sous-marins en
australie et nous pas en france ce qui
permet à l'australie de générer de
l'emploi tout en récupérant certaines
technologies françaises
du coup aujourd'hui la france elle table
plus sur des emplois durables générés
par le service après vente que sur un
pic temporaire due à un besoin de
production diplomatiquement parlant on
se met bien
tous nos clients puisque les contrats
nous engage sur des longues durées
pouvant aller jusqu'à 70 ans mais en
termes de création d'emplois on est
forcé contractuellement de délocaliser
une partie des productions de produit
développé et conçu pour pouvoir rester à
briquet en france attention ça reste
hyper positive économiquement dans le
cadre des sous marins on parle pour le
moment de 4000 emplois de plus en france
et pas que dans l'après vente
c'est toujours bon à prendre mais pour
rester attrayant il faut avoir des
technologies à transférer technologies
qui prennent du temps et de l'argent à
développer argent qui s'acquiert en
vendant des armes dans le transférant
des technologies le cirque paraît tout à
coup un poil moins vertueux parce qu'en
plus le marché de l'armement est hyper
instable et le contrat n'est considérée
comme signé que lorsque le premier
raconte a été versée en attendant les
commandes doivent être prises pour ce
qu'elles sont c'est à dire du virtuel
les contrats s'étalant sur de longues
durées
les échéanciers de paiement font de même
et un coup d'état ou un simple
changement de parti politique peut
vraiment venir enrayer la machine
c'est ce qui s'est passé avec la pologne
par exemple qui avait passé commande de
50 hélicoptères à airbus qui a
finalement annulé il y à peu pour
acheter américain
suite au passage au pouvoir en 2015 du
parti eurosceptique ps tant pis pour les
investissements qu'airbus avait pu
commencer à mettre en place
en plus d'un contrat sur lequel la
pologne avait tout à gagner puisqu'elle
avait négocié 100% 9 7 et 6 un simple
changement de parti politique dans un
pays européen et alliés peut un
bordel pareil on peut être un peu
stressée quand on voit que c'est
l'egypte pays en pole instable ces
dernières années qui est l'un de nos
plus gros clients
ça pue un peu la merde parce que si
demain l'egypte sombre dans le chaos que
vont devenir les arbres qu'on verra
vendus au pays c'est le problème majeur
du commerce des armes à feu
le manque de contrôle sur le business et
le manque de transparence sur les
échanges
aujourd'hui le plus gros problème en
vérité c'est pas qu'on vend des armes
c'est surtout qu'on lui vend à n'importe
qui
et la france n'est pas un super exemple
déjà parce que pour trouver des chiffres
détaillés sur marché français faut se
lever tôt mais parce qu'en plus certains
grands producteurs d'armes et capitaines
d'industrie françaises ont une certaine
culture de la corruption pour acquérir
de nouveaux marchés attention un but est
de l'armement connais pas de pot de vin
me faites pas dire ce que je peux dire
non on préfère parler de frais
commerciaux exceptionnels
voilà ça peut attendre jusqu'au 11 % des
transactions en arabie saoudite
partenaire privilégié de l'état français
le contrat pour la rénovation de la
flotte remporté par la dcns en 1994
1 les mêmes qui feront les sous marins
australiens ont permis de reverser 40 6
millions au prince sultan et 30 millions
à son frère je parle évidemment pas des
i de conflit d'intérêts qui pourraient
concerner serge dassault à la fois
patron l'entreprise qui fabrique nos
fameux rafale pdg du figaro mais aussi
sénateur français les positions plutôt
pratique pour prendre des décisions qui
ne vont pas forcément dans le bon sens
tout en évitant d'en parler dans les
médias puissent contrôler une partie
ça ne va pas aider à trouver des
chiffres exacts sur le rôle de la france
dans les dérives du secteur
ensuite on n'est pas un super exemple
parce que lorsque des gens des ong ou
des états tentent de calmer les
problèmes provoqués par business de
l'armement
on n'est pas foutu de respecter des
accords que l'on a pourtant signé par
exemple tcà c'est un traité qui va dans
le bon sens il est entré en vigueur le
24 décembre 2014 et ce dernier a pour
vocation de réguler le commerce des
armes vers les pays peu pointilleux
concernant le respect des droits de
l'homme aux passagers n'a pas été
ratifié par les us israël ou les émirats
arabes unis comme quoi il ya des points
sur lesquels ces trois là sont d'accord
la france en revanche l'a signé et
ratifié en 2014
mais ça nous a pas empêché de vendre 141
millions d'euros d'armes à l'arabie
saoudite
peu connu pour son respect des droits de
l'homme en 2015 mais bon l'histoire ne
pas faire paniquer les fans de zemmour
au vent aussi à la chine
pourtant sous embargo européen depuis le
massacre de la place tiananmen
et c'est finalement tout le problème de
la politique française elle est pensée à
court terme si demain l'arabie saoudite
soit sous terre un mouvement pourtant
hostile à l'occident et à la france ce
qu'elle est suspecté de faire la guerre
qu'est-ce qu'il empêche de le faire en
fournissant de matériel français même si
les ventes de la france vers l'arabie
saoudite se sont réduites ces dernières
années il est peut-être temps que pays
stop une course à l'armement sans fin
qu'elle finira probablement pas être
incapable de financer autrement qu en
bradant ses découvertes au pays les plus
offrants et dans n'importe quelle
condition qu'ils s'engagent dans une
course sans fin où les avancées
technologiques seraient vendus pour
financer la poursuite de la recherche
autant le faire dans une autre industrie
que celle de l'armement et ça tombe bien
il ya plusieurs industries que ça
pourrait concerner dont celle de
l'énergie avec toute la transition
énergétique à laquelle on assiste et
qu'on va tous être obligés de vivre
si on veut pas avoir à survivre
l'innovation et la création de l'emploi
par l'armement avait du sens à une
certaine époque on a changé d'époque
il était temps changent et le reste
j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu
n'hésitez pas à lâcher un pouce ou à la
partager si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à
me suivre sur les différents réseaux
sociaux que ce soit facebook twitter ou
snap chat
à chaque fois j'ai utilisé de manière
très différente et assez exclusive donc
suivez moi merci à tous les types heures
qui soutiennent ce projet ça me fait
plaisir ça me touche et ça me permet
d'essayer de faire des vidéos de
meilleure qualité à chaque fois toutes
les sources et les infos selon la
description on se retrouve dans quelques
jours pour une nouvelle vidéo love peace
ciao